- [Narrator] This is Pierce,
an African crested porcupine.
(piano music)
The largest porcupine in the world,
it can weigh over 60 pounds.
When alarmed, its coarse quills
can be raised into a
crest, making themselves
look a lot bigger than they are.
It is mostly heavily
armored in its hind quarters
which have short, thick quills.
These quills can get stuck
into its predator's skin.
A good weapon when dealing
with hyenas, leopards
and even lions.
Pierce is mostly a herbivore,
eating roots, bulbs and crops,
along with the occasional insect.
Unfortunately for his species,
crested porcupines are seen
as an agricultural pest
and as open land rapidly shrinks,
they come into closer
quarters with farmers
who will hunt them out of their home.
This is the African crested porcupine.